bonsoir mardi 1er juin bienvenue dans le
journal de tv 78 c'est le tour de
l'actualité locale voici les titres de
cette édition
elles ont été déployées voici un mois à
saint quentin en yvelines le territoire
est doté d'un service de trottinettes
électriques près de 1000 sont en
circulation premier bilan à suivre
auprès des utilisateurs de
l'agglomération et de l'agglomération et
puis invités et jean yves petit
directeur départemental de l'association
prévention routière nous verrons avec
lui que l'utilisation de cette
trottinette n'est pas sans risque
les élections départementales approche
c'est au programme les 20 et 27 juin les
yvelinois devront désigner leurs
quarante deux conseillers répartis dans
21 cantons
comment sont-ils justement découper
explications à suivre enfin c'est l'un
des grands espoirs de l'équitation en
france et il compte bien participer aux
jeux olympiques de 2024 victor l'évêque
vient tout juste de débarquer à maisons
laffitte
le cavalier s'y est installé avec ses
chevaux pour préparer au mieux les
prochaines échéances internationales
on parlera aussi europe dans ce journal
avec le lancement d'un réseau de jeunes
et d'anciens volontaires ce nom sont non
euro pierre france présentation à suivre
dans ce journal
mais avant de développer ces titres la
ville de ben continue ses initiatives
pour lutter contre les violences
intrafamiliales après une convention
signée en mars et une formation à
destination de ses agents municipaux la
commune à participer à une nouvelle
démarche est la distribution ce matin de
sacs de pain un peu particulier déçus
dessus figures et des numéros d'urgence
et un violent être les précisions de
mélanie poquet
au premier coup d'oeil c'est ça qu'a pas
mort et un d'extraordinaire mais on y
trouve des numéros d'urgence et un
violent tôt m une initiative saluée
c'est très bien de mettre des de
diffuser des messages qui sont
importants pour tout le monde vous faire
prendre conscience à tout le monde que
c'est important il faut les aider les
femmes et qui sont violentes et je pense
que c'est bien de tirer l'attention de
des personnes sur ce qui se passe autour
de nous des sacs à pain pensé par la
mêlée de ben les deux boulangeries de la
commune ont été livrés ce mardi 1er juin
je vais essayer de palais m toujours au
même
ça sert à rien je pense qu'il faut
partager un peu plus ma copine
travaillant là dedans
elle m'a un peu sensibilisés à ça et ben
moi j'ai des gens que je connais qui
n'ont subi et tout le monde
les acadiens qui connaît qui ont et qui
a subi sa est un moment pour que ça
s'arrête
un moyen d'entrer d'informer au sein
même des foyers pour la commune de 7500
habitants et milliers de sacs à pain que
nous avons fait imprimer vont permettre
de diffuser toutes ces informations
et on espère qu effectivement si dans
une famille on a ses problèmes à travers
un milieu qu'ils puissent prendre appui
sur ces sacs à pain pour se libérer la
parole dix mille sacs à pain ont été
remis ils viennent compléter les actions
d'associations et de gendarmerie en 2019
près de 200 femmes hommes et enfants
sont morts de violences intrafamiliales
le point à présent sur la vaccination
contre le coc vie de 19 dans les
yvelines au 30 mai 487 1876 personnes
étaient primo injectés dans le
département cinquante mille de plus en
une semaine soit une hausse de 11 4%
la vaccination qui est ouvert depuis
hier à partir de 18 ans et sans critères
de santé d'ailleurs un nouveau
vaccinodromes a été mise en service
aujourd'hui à mantes-la-jolie il
réalisera il réalisera 6000 injection
par semaine au total près de 196 1500
personnes ont été complètement vaccinés
dans les yvelines
après un mois environ d'utilisation
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines fait le bilan du service de
trottinettes électriques est de bons
chiffres mais avec quelques ajustements
comme vous allez le voir dans ce sujet
d'eléonore sinoquet et de bérangère
bourgoin lors de la première utilisation
c'est un peu impressionnant quand on n'a
pas l'habitude mais c'est assez simple
d'utilisation
qu'est ce que j'ai vu c'est plutôt bien
utilisés je pensais plutôt une bonne
chose moi je les ai utilisés mais
seulement en vacances pour se déplacer à
ces pratiques des usagers qui dans
l'ensemble respecte les règles et une
cohabitation qui se passe plutôt bien
après près d'un mois d'utilisation le
premier bilan du service de trottinettes
électriques est plutôt satisfaisant on
constate que le service justement
rencontre un franc succès
un lancement qui a vraiment été très
performant ça nous avait agréablement
surpris l'opérateur aussi qui fait son
son deuxième lancement mondial le plus
le plus efficace dans les dix premiers
jours dix mille personnes ont utilisé
les trottinettes électriques pour
environ 6000 trajet de bons chiffres
mais certains utilisateurs adoptent
parfois de mauvais comportements au
départ un certain nombre de mineurs qui
est une idée si trottinette
hu a aussi parfois encore deux personnes
par trottinette mais ça a tendance à
s'améliorer assez assez largement depuis
que nous sommes passés de 4 150 amis
l'engin de dégradations ont également
été constatés pour régler cela des
ajustements vont être faits les polices
municipales de nos douze communes sont
évidemment averti donc il ya un volet
toujours pédagogie et de sensibilisation
et un volet de sanctions quand la
personne est en infraction au code de la
route
elles sont toutes équipées d'une puce
gps et la personne aujourd'hui qui
réserve sa trottinette et qui ne
remplace pas la trottinette sur une
station clairement défini se verra
attribuer des pénalités financières puis
nous aurons dans les prochaines semaines
également un système qui permettra via
l'application de relier la carte
d'identité et donc d'avoir l'âge de la
personne qui veut réserver débloquer sa
trottinette et si c'est un mineur il ne
pourra plus le faire l'agglomération
continue donc ses campagnes de
prévention via ses réseaux sociaux mais
reste sereine ans bientôt un mois près
de 2000 pas ses abonnements ont été
achetés
et le service de trottinettes
électriques a pour le moment
de beaux jours devant lui à saint
quentin en yvelines un usage des
trottinettes qui n'est pas sans risque
d'après les derniers chiffres de
l'accidentalité paru cette semaine
774 usagers d'engins de déplacements
personnels non autorisées ont été
blessées en 2020 + 40 % par rapport à
sept personnes sont mortes un chiffre
lui qui est en diminution de 30% et on
parle de ce sujet avec jean yves petit
qui était avec nous en visioconférence
bonsoir vous êtes le directeur
départemental de l'association
prévention routière alors je précise que
les engins de déplacements personnels
motorisés comprennent les trottinettes
électriques mais aussi les gyropodes les
monocycles les overboard on les désigne
en fait sous l'acronyme de dpm leur
entrée au journal officiel remonte au 25
octobre 2019 jean yves petit c'est un
sujet finalement qui est assez nouveau
avec une réglementation qui est récente
oui heureusement à cette réglementation
est gris heureusement puisque tous ces
engins que vous n'avez numéro et on les
a vu fleurir partout en france depuis
une bonne dizaine d'années dans la plus
grande anarchie
on voyait vraiment n'importe quoi et
enfin c'est arrivé dans le code de la
route avec des règles des définitions et
donc enfin on peut expliquer les bons
comportements ou d'usagé effectivement
il ya un nombre de blessés qui augmente
je le disais plus 40% en 2020 par
rapport à 2019 vous le disiez c'est
devenu un nouveau sujet peut-être un
sujet même de société sur sur cette
thématique de la circulation
oui pour nous à la prévention routière
c'est un sujet a effectivement oui dont
bas que nous suivons forcément puisque
ça fait partie de notre de notre mission
en appelant les les usagers la plus
grande prudence et à respecter les
règles qui sont dans le code de la route
nous allons peut-être pouvoir parler on
va en parler dans un instant
effectivement et je le disais aussi le
nombre de morts lui a reculé en 2020 au
contraire à -30% avec sept décès
finalement c'est dans la même dynamique
que la tendance globale on va dire en
matière de sécurité routière les
chiffres ont été finalisés cette semaine
notamment à un recul de 22 % de la
mortalité sur les routes en 2020 c'est
une bonne nouvelle ou c'est tout de même
à nuancer
jean yves petit car on sait que l'année
dernière il y avait il ya eu 2
confinement est forcément avec ses
confinement moins d'usagers aussi sur
les routes bah bien sûr que c'était que
je vous avais dit je crois quand on en
avait déjà parlé
les confinements ont eu bien sûr des des
effets positifs sur la mortalité sur la
route c'est évident mais cet apport
artificiel évidemment est donc
maintenant que les la circulation
reprend on a vu par exemple au mois de
mai il ya eu dans les yvelines cinq tués
dont quatre motards donc malheureusement
il est à craindre que la mortalité
repartent à la hausse et les
trottinettes et dpn jeu malheureusement
vont suivre la même la même voie
il y aura plus de circulation donc plus
d'un cri lan ou peut-être plus
d'accidents pour ses oeufs dpm revenons
justement autres hot in est avec tous
les bons conseils finalement à pour
circuler en toute prudence déjà au
niveau de la loi
quelles sont les règles générales jean
yves petit pour une bonne utilisation de
la trottinette avant justement de
prendre ce moyen de déplacement quelles
sont les règles auxquelles il faut se
plier
alors il ya des règles pour l'engin
lui-même lors ge a lui même quand on le
lourd suppose qu'il est bien équipé mais
quand on l'achète il faut il embrouille
de répéter comme un vélo avec des freins
des feux catadioptres est ce honnête ça
c'est pour l'ange à lui même maintenant
pour le
le pilote il faut considérer que doit
être équipée chorale cycliques
c'est-à-dire un gilet dès qu'il fait
nuit
même en ville et un casque en permanence
en permanence surtout que élan alors oui
pardon où il va parce que justement sur
ce thème du casque il n'est pas
obligatoire mais il est vivement
recommandé un le port du masque le port
du casque est donc pas le port du masque
le port du masque lui est toujours une
obligation dans les rues yvelinoise mais
le port du casque sur les trottinettes
et édith m'ont recommandé
oui le port du casque est recommandée
d'autant plus que j'ai vu il ya les
profils est normalement la vitesse est
bridée à 25 kilomètres heure mais vous
avez le plus vu dans internet qui est
des ondes et puis xp pour les trois
pilotes qui vont jusqu'à 110 km heure je
trouve ça complètement aberrant il est
vu des gens à versailles faire de la
trottinette sur des avenues il allait
facilement à 60 kilomètres/heure
donc je trouve que c'est foncièrement
dangereux parce que c'est trottinette à
doivent être je crois pour une
utilisation villa à 25 km heure c'est
bien ça la vie tête pour utiliser ces
engins sur la voie publique doit être
limité à 25 kilomètres heure mais c'est
comme les grosses bmw ou les audi qui
vont du cas de 150 à leur fait pareil en
termes aussi d'âge il y à des critères
je crois que ce à partir de 12 ans 1
qu'on peut utiliser qu'on peut monter
sur une trottinette électrique est aussi
ce qu il faut préciser c'est qu'il ne
faut pas qu'il y ait de passagers on est
tout seul sur sur cette routine est le
code de la route précise qu il faut
avoir au moins 12 ans et que c'est pour
une seule personne
on en voit malheureusement beaucoup à
deux voire trois personnes dont un
enfant et ont alors la circulation doit
se faire exactement comme pour les vélos
donc sur les bancs des voies cyclables
sur les voies vertes et sur la chaussée
urbaines quand y'a rien de caen il ya
rien de particulier avec deux
dérogations qui peuvent exister pour en
faire sur les trottoirs par dérogation
du maire dans ce cas là et pour en faire
également sur les routes secondes
r c'est à dire les routes limitées à 80
km heure là aussi fait normalement
interdite sauf dérogation
une dernière question jean yves petit si
on ne respecte pas ces règles justement
à quelle sanction s'expose ton quel type
d'amande la catégorie de l'amande
oui voilà on faire attention c'est le
message de prévention à passer de toute
façon on retrouve toutes les
informations sur le site de
l'association prévention routière et qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci jean
yves petit d'avoir été avec nous au
revoir et je le rappelle vous êtes le
directeur départemental de l'association
prévention routière
toujours en matière de déplacements
c'est en vigueur depuis ce mardi 1er
juin les véhicules équipés d'une
vignette critères 4 est désormais
interdite à la circulation dans le
périmètre à l'intérieur de l'autoroute
a86 il s'agit à des diesels de plus de
15 ans une nouvelle étape dans la mise
en place de la zone à faible émission du
grand paris est la mesure court la
semaine du lundi au vendredi de 8h à 20h
s'agit bien de véhicules voilà on en
voit à l'écran est dans un premier temps
pas de verbalisation à prévoir de
simples contrôles pédagogiques seront
effectués et du côté des transports en
commun le réseau stibus perturbé ce
mardi conséquence de la grève illimitée
déclenchée par les salariés des cars
périer est les conducteurs demandent une
revalorisation de leurs salaires et une
prime de 350 euros pour avoir assurer le
bon fonctionnement du trafic pendant les
confinements pour le moment les
négociations entre la direction et les
syndicats n'aboutissent pas c'est la
deuxième mobilisation depuis le mois de
mars
ce mardi 27 lignes ski bus étaient
concernés rester informés sur ce qui vu
ce qu'on sait faire
et les élections départementales sont au
programme les 20 et 27 juin prochain
cantonales jusqu'en 2011 ce scrutin a
changé de nom en 2015
mais les électeurs sont toujours appelés
à voter pour des cantons combien y en
at-il exactement comment sont ils
déterminés toutes les explications avec
mélanie potier 21 cantons c'est le
découpage électoral dans les yvelines
pour les élections départementales pensé
lors du redécoupage dès 2014 le nombre
de cantons dans un département comptant
plus de 500000 habitants ne peut être
inférieure à 17 avec près d'un million
cinq cent mille habitants
les yvelines sont donc passés de 39 à 21
cantons dès le scrutin de 2015 un peu
d'histoire les limites des cantons ont
été tracées en 1801 le redécoupage de
2014 c'est le fruit d'une volonté
gouvernementale de tenir compte des
évolutions démographiques et les
nouvelles délimitations s'appuie sur les
chiffres de l'insee de 2013 alors
comment sont répartis les commune
yvelinoise chaque canton doit désormais
regroupé le même nombre d'habitants avec
une marge de plus ou moins 20 %
explications un million cinq cent mille
habitants / 21 cantons cela nous donne
une moyenne de 71 mille habitants + 20 %
nous amène à 85 mille habitants
c'est le cas de sartrouville le canton
le plus peuplé des yvelines avec 83
mille habitants -20% cette fois ça nous
donne 56 1800 habitants dans les
yvelines c'est le cas du canton de
limoux qui est composé de 57 mille
habitants alors pour respecter cette
répartition la composition des cantons
peut sembler un peu disparate par
exemple comptons de bonnières-sur-seine
regroupe soixante neuf communes maurepas
elle quitte son canton composé de
coignières elancourt et la verrière la
commune saint-quentinoise rejoint le
canton alors appelé de chevreuse avec 14
autres communes nos repas étant là la
plus grande ville le canton de chevreuse
prend le nom de maurepas il y à aussi
celui de montigny le bretonneux qui est
composé de deux communes
monti nez et guyancourt et le cas le
plus particulier c'est celui de la ville
de versailles puisqu'elle est coupée en
deux le canton versailles ne regroupe
qu'une partie de la cité royale et
représente 65 mille habitants celui de
versailles 2 et l'addition 2,5 ville
bucs jouy en josas les loges en josas
viroflay evil is heavy de l'accoupler et
bien sûr la deuxième partie de
versailles
si vous avez en tête un projet de
création d'entreprise ce rendez vous est
fait pour vous demain mercredi un point
d'accueil et d'information sera
organisée sur le sujet attrape ce sera à
proximité du marché des merisiers à côté
du bureau de poste une après-midi
proposée par l'association adie qui
financent et accompagnent des porteurs
de projets par le biais du microcrédit
demain sur place vous pourrez rencontrer
différents acteurs en plus de l'adie
pour l'emploi positifs planète
initiative saint quentin en yvelines et
des banques
rendez vous ce mercredi 2 juin de 14h à
17h la semaine européenne de la jeunesse
avait lieu jusqu'à dimanche dernier
cette année le programme erasmus plus a
choisi de faire un focus sur le corps
européen de solidarité une journée
spéciale a été d'ailleurs organisé
samedi c'était à saint germain en laye
pour lancer un réseau d'anciens
volontaires sont non euro pierce france
interview collectées par bixente mayence
insisté ban
[Musique]
treize volontaires se sont réunis à
saint germain en laye pour la youth oui
que c'était une une journée
d'informations et de témoignages sur les
programmes qui composent le corps hors
pair de solidarité donc c'est l'un des
deux dispositifs européens qui sont qui
sont mis en oeuvre en france par
l'agencé rasmusson plus jeunesse et
sports le corps européen de solidarité
qu aucun de solidarité qui permet
notamment à des jeunes de partir en
volontariat pour une durée qui peut
aller jusqu'à un an dans un autre pays
européen ou même dans un pays voisin de
l'europe réseau de jeunes volontaires ou
anciens volontaires qui sont
ambassadeurs du programme et qui ont
pour mission de d'informer les autres
jeunes de l'existence de ce programme et
les encourager aussi à vivre une
expérience de mobilité en europe ou à
l'international
ta prêt à accueillir de nouveaux jeunes
donc si toute personne qui a déjà
participé un programme du corps hors
pair de solidarité femmes
un des volets du commentaire de
solidarité est intéressé pour nous
rejoindre vous pouvez juste nous
contacter via les réseaux sociaux avant
de vous laisser le compte bien faire les
jeux olympiques de 2024 victor l'évêque
22 ans est l'une des grandes promesses
de l'équitation en france il vient tout
juste de déménager à maisons-laffitte
avec ses chevaux l'illinois a pris cette
décision pour se préparer au mieux aux
grandes échéances internationales
michael et demi d'euros la rencontrer
bonjour ses lecteurs l'évêque bienvenue
dans les écuries
arrivé il ya tout juste un mois le
cavalier international de concours
complet se sont déjà chez lui à maisons
laffitte
cette yvelinois pure souche a quitté la
boissière école près de rambouillet pour
déménager avec sept de ses chevaux
décision mûrement réfléchie
il y avait un aspect géographique
puisque je suis sur la fin de mes études
à sciences po voilages intègre un master
marketing et sociétés s'étaient
importante pour moi
pour terminer les deux ans qui me reste
de me rapprocher un peu de paris il y
avait aussi la nécessité de voilà me
recentrer un peu plus sur mes chevaux de
compétition j'ai amené que mes chevaux
vraiment de haut niveau à
maisons-laffitte c'était aussi un choix
personnel
voilà je partage cette passion et ce
sport avec ma copine et puis voilà
c'était je pense important et
intéressant de nous entraîner ensemble
avec cette installation le cavalier de
22 ans espère également trouver un cadre
de vie propice à la pratique de
l'équitation tous les jours victor
l'évêque va s'entraîner dans cette ville
baptisée la cité du cheval en raison de
son importante activité équestre et de
son hippodrome
je crois que ça offre des perspectives
d'entraînement exceptionnel c'est ce que
je recherche aussi avant tout c'est la
possibilité de pouvoir avoir accès aux
pistes avoir accès à la forêt et puis
aussi tous les arts de travail l'écart
de dressage les cas d'obstacle essentiel
évidemment à la pratique de manse par
haut niveau une ville qui lui permettra
peut-être d'accéder à ses plus grands
rêves avec notamment ligne de mire les
jeux olympiques de 2024
une compétition dans laquelle libinois
espère briller après avoir remporté
quatre titres de champion d'europe chez
les jeunes ça sera je l'espère mes
premiers jeux olympiques
j'ai beaucoup entendu dire que les jeux
olympiques c'est une atmosphère très
différente
on dit souvent qu'il faut aussi mesurer
une première fois avant d'être
performant on verra j'essaierai de me
préparer de la meilleure manière
possible
et puis si j'y vais oui je me battrai à
tout prix pour une médaille une médaille
olympique viendrait valider de belle
manière ce choix de déménager à
maisons-laffitte maintenant à place au
travail
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité très belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]